I always have friends where I work and
if I don't have friends at the job I
will not keep the job so when I was
fired the last time from this show
people say to me were you okay with that
and my answer is I was happy I think I'm
gonna miss the the friends that I have
here Joy behar's view in 2013 fired but
fine I'm talking about people and the
producers and the and the publicist and
the makeup and hair people I'm gonna
miss that the most I think now we know
Joy returned to the daytime talker in
2015 and she's been there ever since
which begs the question why are the
ladies rehashing old news like when Joy
got fired in 2013 well because it was
one of Thursday's Hot Topics the rise of
more employees working remotely has
apparently led to a decline in the
so-called work best friend I always have
friends where I work and if I don't have
friends at the job I will not keep the
job you know I've had a lot of therapy
and that's what you need at the view
yeah remember when the comedian was
sacked from the iconic talk show a
decade ago Joy's revisiting that time in
her life and explaining why she wasn't
exactly sad to go when I was fired the
last time from this show
people say to me were you okay with that
and my answer is I was happy because all
my friends had left already so so there
was no reason to stay anymore really
yeah I mean it all your friends
you had just come on and my backstage
friends had left oh God yeah and I don't
like to work when I don't have friends
because the selfish part says no stay I
said Joy let's chain ourselves to death
well joy had at least one ride or die
and Sherry Shepherd I was summarily
dismissed and then I was They begged me
to come back and here I am of course Joy
is an OG panelist to help launch the
show in 1997. it was good news when a
woman has a baby in her late years she
can breastfeed standing up but a long
time viewers seem to think it had
something to do with friction between
joy and then panelist Elizabeth
Hasselbeck confidence is what it is
fast forward to 2015 Joy was asked back
to the table I am I'm confident about it
because I get along with people
and you know what it's just television
let's not get carried away here
you know back to Thursday's Hot Topic
panel moderator Whoopi Goldberg who
joined the show in 2007 gave Joy a
little Flack for what she said
yeah and I don't like to work when I
don't have friends
at work
oh nice there's no other reason to go to
work
friends a long time
because you were not the backstage
friends I was talking about backstage I
know I know
it's like a friendly argument is a great
thing on the show you know people who
disagree with each other I always used
to say in the meetings in the morning
don't pick topics where we all agree
[Music]